Бігом на підконтрольну Києву територію
за пенсіями до Великодня.
Та до банкоматів Ощадбанку ще далеко.
Хоча між блокпостом в окупованій Горлівці
і контрольним пунктом "Майорське" лише 2 кілометри,
цей шлях люди проходять годин за 5, а то і більше.
Вистояти черги літнім людям дуже важко -
і фізично, і психологічно.
84-х річна Єлизавета Олексіївна
до таких труднощів вже звикла.
Жінка каже, що, крім української пенсії,
інших доходів у неї немає. Тому доводиться, попри вік і страх,
вибиратися зі свого підвалу в окупованому передмісті Донецька,
де жінка переховується від обстрілів,
і їхати у Краматорськ, до місця реєстрації
як внутрішньо переміщеної особи.
Для мене це питання життя.
В мене 35 років стажу, маю статус дитини війни.
Але ось бачите, в якому я стані.
Забирати пенсію літні люди, що живуть в окупації, мають самі.
Їм можуть заблокувати виплати, якщо вони двічі на півроку
особисто не проходитимуть ось таку процедуру фізичної ідентифікації.
Ще одна підстава заблокувати виплати:
якщо з блокпостів надійде інформація,
що людина була відсутня на підконтрольній Україні території
понад два місяці.
Тож до окупованого Донбасу перед святами
не усі повертаються з грошима.
Я дійсно не перетинала блокпост 60 діб.
Тому що я дуже хворіла в листопаді.
І не змогла з цієї причини. І вони через це пенсію забрали.
Я не знаю, чи зможу я її відновити.
За офіційними даними, за пенсіями з окупованих районів Донеччини
приїжджають не менше 100 тисяч людей.
Безперечно, процедура виснажлива.
Але в ситуації, коли на окупованій території
українські банки не працюють, це - єдиний вихід,
переконаний донецький військовий губернатор.
Зрозуміло, що держава Україна хоче бачити, кому платить.
Чи жива ця людина, чи не жива.
Чи карточка банківська в цієї людини,
чи в неї відібрали бойовики.
Чи, вибачте мене, чи син алкоголік,
який отримує пенсію
і полишає стареньких без засобів для існування.
Аргументи влади Олена, яка з великими труднощами
привезла свою хвору мати з Луганщини, розуміє.
Але не впевнена, що здоров’я матері дозволить привезти її
через два місяці на наступну ідентифікацію до Ощадбанку.
Це люди просто викреслені з життя.
Три роки ці…Життя проходить повз них
За офіційними даними, на окупованому Донбасі
залишилися близько 300 тисяч хворих людей,
які так і не змогли звернутися по соціальні виплати.